Ich bin ein Cyborg, weil ich
ein effizienterer Mensch sein will,
nicht ein besserer Mensch.
Aber ich glaube,
dass ich mehr aus meinem
eigenen Leben herausholen kann,
dass ich mehr
aus fremden Leben herausholen kann,
indem ich Denkanstösse verursache.
Also glaube ich, dass ich
ein effizienterer Mensch bin,
aber nicht besser.
Besser müsste man werten,
aber ich sehe das gar nicht wertend.
Für mich ist Fortschritt
der wichtigste Bestandteil
vom Leben.
Ohne Fortschritt
gibt es keine Entwicklung.
Wenn wir jetzt nicht anfangen,
uns selbst zu entwickeln,
den Übermenschen schaffen
und die nächste Stufe,
stagnieren wir für alle Zeiten.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist für mich
weder für die Zukunft
noch für den Menschen sinnvoll.
Ich trage Implantate in mir,
die Funktionen haben.
Ich bin die Mischung
zwischen Mensch und Maschine.
* Sanfte Musik *
# Take a little walk
to the edge of the town.
# Go across the tracks.
Es sieht düster aus,
weil ich gerne düster lebe.
Die Leute nennen mich Grufti,
und ich glaube, das bin ich
im klassischen Sinne auch.
Ich stehe auf Totenköpfe,
Pentagramme und das düstere Zeug.
Ich mag den Grufti-Kitsch!
Angefangen habe ich mit 18.
Wir sind in den Tierhandel gegangen.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Jetzt setze ich mir mal
so ein Teil!"
Wir haben uns so einen Chip gesetzt.
Ich habe ihn mir
in die Handfläche gespritzt.
Ich sagte: "Jetzt lege ich los und
schaue, was ich damit machen kann."
Ich konnte damit
leider nicht viel machen,
weil mir Knowledge
und Community fehlten,
aber ich war neugierig.
Ich fand mich selbst ziemlich cool.
Ich legte einfach los.
In der rechten Hand
trage ich einen Low-Frequency-Chip.
Den sieht man leider nicht,
nur die Narbe.
In meiner linken Hand
sieht man den Chip.
Da ist ein High-Frequency-Chip drin.
Dann habe ich noch einen ganz alten.
Er ist 17 Jahre alt.
Den habe ich hier drin.
Ich habe ihn mir
vom Tierarzt spritzen lassen.
Er ist leider schon tot.
Und dasselbe habe ich hier unten -
auch einen toten Chip.
Was ich machen kann: Ich kann mein
Telefon mit meinem Chip entsperren.
Jetzt muss ich die Stelle finden -
zack!
Jetzt ist das Telefon entsperrt.
Ich kann mir eine Textdatei
als Datensatz hinterlegen,
eine URL zu einer Website,
die ich toll finde,
eine Suchfunktion.
Ich kann mein Facebook-, Twitter-,
LinkedIn-Profil hinterlegen,
wenn ich das sharen möchte,
meinen Steam-Account.
Für die Paranoiden kann ich
mein Bitcoin-Konto hinterlegen.
Ich habe mich für Chips entschieden,
obwohl es auch
mit meinem Gesicht möglich ist,
mein iPhone zu entsperren,
oder mit meinem Fingerabdruck.
Das heisst nicht,
dass der Fingerabdruck
oder das Face-Unlock
weniger praktisch wären.
Im Grunde
ist der Chip unpraktischer,
denn ich muss
einen Vorgang mehr machen.
Aber ich möchte damit
einen Antrieb schaffen.
Ich möchte durch Konsum
Interesse wecken.
D.h., je mehr ich mit Chips,
Upgrades, Wearables usw. konsumiere,
versuche ich mit den Leuten,
die das auch vertreten,
einen Markt zu schaffen.
D.h., wenn wir konsumieren,
wird irgendjemand
irgendwann Interesse haben,
damit Geld zu verdienen.
Meine Bodymodification-
und Subdermal-Implantate
haben effektiv keine Funktion.
Das ist rein, weil ich
mein Aussehen ändern möchte, ja.
# Take a little walk
to the edge of town.
# And go across the tracks.
# Where the viaduct looms,
like a bird of doom.
Ich lernte Mike kennen,
als ich einen Vortrag hielt.
Er meldete sich als Zuschauer.
Wir vertreten uns
in der Öffentlichkeit gegenseitig.
Also wir teilen sehr viel
in unserem Spektrum,
unserer Wahrnehmung,
unserer Realitätswahrnehmung.
Und wir haben den gleichen Gedanken.
Ich wurde von der Fantasy Basel
eingeladen,
über Transhumanismus zu sprechen,
über das Cyborg-Leben,
weil ich mich als Cyborg bezeichne,
um Aufklärung zu betreiben und
den Leuten zu zeigen, was wir tun,
und mit den Leuten zu agieren.
Die Leute hier sind mutig.
Sie sind bereit, sich
in eine andere Rolle zu begeben,
andere Menschen zu akzeptieren
und sich neue Ideen anzuhören.
Ich finde das hier sehr gut passend.
Wir haben gestern
darüber gesprochen:
Du hast gesagt, du würdest jetzt auf
dein physisches Leben verzichten,
um in digitaler Form weiterzuleben.
Du würdest jetzt schon
den Schritt machen und nicht warten.
Absolut!
Hast du keine Angst
vor der Unendlichkeit?
Für mich ist Unendlichkeit
nicht so ein Problem,
denn wenn wir einen Körper haben,
der immer funktioniert,
der immer fähig ist, da ist,
verstehe ich nicht,
warum die Unendlichkeit
ein Problem sein sollte.
Ich möchte ja jetzt
auch nicht sterben,
warum sollte ich in 1'000 Jahren
sterben wollen?
Wenn dein biologischer Körper
irgendwann an sein Ende kommt,
dann lebt einfach
die Maschine weiter,
aber du selbst bist ja trotzdem
an dein Ende gekommen.
Ja, also für mich als Kopie
geht es genau so weiter.
Ich führe dann mein Leben weiter -
halt einfach als Kopie.
Aber die Entwicklung, die danach
stattfindet, das bin weiterhin ich.
Also ich mache
eine digitale Kopie vom Verstand,
vom Gehirn an dem Punkt.
D.h., ich bin eins zu eins dasselbe
an dem Punkt,
an dem ich gespalten werde.
D.h.,
ich verändere mich erst danach.
Habt ihr zu viel Science-Fiction
gesehen?
Ich glaube, Mind uploading ist keine
Fantasie aus der Science-Fiction.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir zu viel
Science-Fiction geguckt haben.
Ich glaube, dass uns Science-Fiction
den Mut gegeben hat,
Wünsche zu äussern.
Dass ein Geist und ein Bewusstsein
digitalisiert werden,
ist tatsächlich irgendwann möglich.
Dass ein Geist an zwei Stellen
digital existieren kann -
als Kopie, als Klon,
wie man das dann auch immer sieht -,
wird auch passieren.
Ob ich es erleben werde,
ist eine andere Geschichte.
Dass man einen Geist in
einen anderen Körper swappen kann,
das ist das Body- oder Wirtswappen,
wird auch passieren.
Wenn du dir vorstellst:
Du bist sterbenskrank.
Du hast die Möglichkeit,
dein Bewusstsein
in einen anderen Körper zu stecken
oder für alle Zeiten
digital weiterzuleben -
die Leute werden das wollen!
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich kam in die Schweiz,
weil eine Cocktailbar in Basel
einen Barmanager suchte,
was mein Spezialgebiet ist.
Also ich arbeite mit Cocktails.
Ich bin eigentlich
der klassische Barkeeper.
Aber ich arbeite inzwischen
eher in der Geschäftsführung.
Ich kümmere mich um Konzepte,
um das Angebot
und um das,
was administrativ passiert.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Im Beruf merkt man eigentlich nichts
von meinem Privatleben.
Es kann mal passieren,
dass jemand meine Arme sieht
und ihm auffällt,
dass ich Implantate trage.
Grundsätzlich
trenne ich das ganz bewusst.
Ich finde, im Beruf
hat das auch nichts zu suchen.
Mein privates Pleasure soll nicht
im Beruf reflektiert werden.
Der Mensch ist an einem Punkt
angelangt, wo er stagniert.
Wir haben keine Entwicklung mehr.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ein Mensch glücklich ist,
wenn er auf dem Stand bleibt,
wo er ist.
Eine rein geistige Entwicklung
reicht mir nicht.
Das ist auch für die Zukunft
nicht ausreichend.
Es muss eine körperliche
und physische Entwicklung geben.
Das heisst ja nicht, dass das eine
das andere ausschliessen muss.
Aber das eine
kann durch das andere erfolgen.
Wenn wir eine geistige Entwicklung
durch bewusstes Leben,
bewusstes Konsumieren
von Information usw. durchmachen,
entwickeln wir automatisch
das Bedürfnis,
auch physische Entwicklung zu haben.
Das ist ganz normal.
Wenn du dir über deinen Körper
so bewusst bist,
möchtest du Makel entfernen,
du möchtest Schwachstellen
entfernen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Meine Schilddrüse ist nicht gesund.
Und für mich ist natürlich
ein persönliches Interesse,
dass ich irgendwann
die Schilddrüsenfunktion,
die dieses Ding momentan noch trägt,
mit einer Maschine ersetzen kann.
Ganz klar!
Ich möchte nicht darauf verzichten,
sondern es ersetzen.
Ich möchte nicht fragil sein.
Ich möchte nicht auf
Körperfunktionen verzichten müssen.
Wenn ich die Möglichkeit habe,
meine Schilddrüse,
die nicht richtig funktioniert,
durch eine Maschine zu ersetzen,
die piekfein funktioniert,
solange ich sie anständig behandle,
ist das das absolut Grösste.
Ich würde wohl der Maschine mehr
vertrauen als meiner Schilddrüse.
Menschen, die mir nahestehen,
sind das gewohnt.
Sie sagen:
"Steve spinnt mal wieder!"
"Er macht mal wieder Quatsch,
guckt auf eine Spinnerei
und tut sich das an!"
Man wird viel belächelt,
aber auf eine respektvolle Art
aus meinem Umfeld.
Es gibt tatsächlich Kritiker,
die das sehr verurteilen.
Das gibt es natürlich auch.
Das geht bis zu Beschimpfungen.
Das gehört dazu.
Aber ich wurde noch nie angegriffen
im Sinne von so diffamiert
oder beleidigt, dass ich sagen muss:
"Ich muss das verstecken."
Das auf keinen Fall.
Hallo! Alles fresh?
- Hey!
Und dir?
- Nicht schlecht, danke!
* Sanfte Musik *
Schön, danke!
Es ist etwas grösser als das,
was wir hatten.
Das wird lustig.
Ich lasse mir
ein XBT-Chip-Implantat setzen.
Das Tolle an dem Chip ist:
Er kann meine Körperwärme
an der Stelle,
wo ich ihn implantiere, analysieren,
und ich kann es auswerten.
Dazu könnte man aber auch
einen Fiebermesser benutzen.
Könnte man,
aber ich finde das fetziger.
Es kann einfach sein,
dass ich einen Muskel erwische.
Es ist nicht so schlimm,
wie es klingt.
Ich habe hier
ja auch einen Muskel drin.
Es tut weh,
aber es ist nicht so tragisch.
Aber wenn ich genug nah bin,
geht es.
Ich habe schon einige Chips
bei anderen gesetzt.
bei mir selbst gesetzt.
Und ...
Ja, ich würde sagen,
ich bin darin sehr erfahren.
Wir arbeiten hier steril.
Das sollte eigentlich
kein Problem darstellen.
Der Chip
ist steril in der Nadel drin.
Deswegen sieht man ihn auch nicht,
wenn man ihn implantiert.
Er wird durch die Kanüle
in die Haut gedrückt.
Tja ...
* Steve lacht. *
Dann gehe ich einfach etwa 2 cm ...
Bist du bereit?
Ich glaube, der wird wehtun.
- Das kann sein.
Kann sein.
Shit, der zieht aber!
Warte, er ist gleich drin!
Entschuldige!
* Steve stöhnt. *
Uh!
* Beide lachen. *
Das hat wehgetan, oder?
Das habe ich mir gedacht.
Geht's?
- Alles gut!
Ja, ja, alles cool!
Wo haben wir die Pflaster?
Ah, da!
Tipptopp!
- So!
So!
Danke!
- Bitte schön!
So!
Ich möchte eigentlich
meine komplette Identität
auf meinem Chip haben.
Das fängt beim Schlüssel an,
dass ich meine Tür öffnen darf,
also meine Berechtigung,
meine ID-Karte, am besten auch
meine Bewilligung und mein Geld.
Das möchte ich alles haben.
Ich möchte mich
von diesem Zeug befreien.
Mike kann seine Tür schon öffnen.
Er kratzt aber auch mit den Fingern,
dass er bezahlen darf.
Wir warten eigentlich nur darauf,
dass uns das jemand gestattet.
* Technomusik *
Musik war für mich immer
absolut wichtig -
also in jeglicher Hinsicht, ja.
* Technomusik *
Mein Ziel ist es tatsächlich,
diese ganzen Knöpfe,
die ich hier überall
verteilt habe ...
Das sind ja nichts anderes
als Midi-Trigger.
Hinter jedem Knopf und jeder
Bewegung ist ein kleines Signal.
Das wird
an meinen Computer geschickt,
und der Computer macht das,
was ich hier drücke.
Ich möchte das darauf übertragen.
Das ist ein EEG-Gerät.
Damit kann ich momentan
einen kleinen Orbitkopter steuern.
Das ist ein kleiner Hubschrauber.
Er sieht aus wie eine Drohne.
Mit dem kann ich
drei bis vier Befehle ausführen.
So!
Ich möchte aber jeden Befehl,
den ich hier habe,
mit meinem Übertragungsgerät,
das über Hirnströme funktioniert,
komplett steuern.
Ich triggere eigentlich Befehle,
indem ich daran denke, ja.
Das ist mal eine Konzentration!
Das sind die Hirnwellen,
die von diesem Gerät erfasst werden.
Und umso besser sie sind, umso mehr
Ausschläge habe ich hier oben.
D.h.,
ich habe mich darauf konzentriert.
Dann geht meine Meditation hoch.
Wenn ich z.B. überlegen muss,
was ich sagen will ...
Jetzt kann ich gerade mal probieren,
ob es wieder steigt.
Siehst du? Jetzt geht es hoch.
Ich fange an, mich zu konzentrieren.
Wenn ich ein EEG
mit 32 Ablesepunkten habe
anstatt nur einem,
kann ich natürlich
deutlich mehr Effizienz rausholen.
In der utopischen Vorstellung,
dass ich das je schaffen sollte,
könnte ich mich setzen
und alles steuern,
ohne einen Finger krumm zu machen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir
mit der Technik verschmelzen.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass es unabdingbar ist.
Und ich gehe davon aus,
dass es in einer gewissen Zeit
tatsächlich so normal ist,
dass man sich eher wundert,
dass es nicht früher passiert ist.
Der Chip funktioniert tadellos.
Die Schwellung ist weg,
das Wundwasser ist weg.
Er macht seinen Dienst einwandfrei.
Ich bekomme konstante Körper-
temperaturwärme von der Stelle.
Ich bin mehr als zufrieden.
Es hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Ich möchte meinen Körper
jederzeit überwachen können.
Also meine Motivation
ist die Medizin.
Ich möchte jederzeit auf meinem iPad
- oder was auch immer ich benutze -
alles sehen,
was in meinem Körper vorgeht -
von meinem Blutzucker
bis zu meiner Muskelentzündung,
bis
zu meiner Zahnfleischrückbildung,
bis zu meinem Haarwuchs, alles!
Ich möchte jeden Punkt nachvoll-
ziehen und auch steuern können.
* Sanfte Musik *
Möchtest du den Tod besiegen?
Ob ich den Tod besiegen möchte?
Wenn ich mutig bin:
ja, ganz ehrlich.
Wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte,
ein echtes Leben
in der Unsterblichkeit zu verbringen
und meinen Tod
selbst bestimmen zu können,
das wäre wahrscheinlich das Grösste,
was ich erreichen könnte.
Und ich möchte es.
Ich könnte tatsächlich
mein Potenzial völlig ausschöpfen,
denn ich habe dieses Zeitfenster
nicht mehr.
Das ist der Kernpunkt,
wo wir hinwollen.